franz kafka is regarded as one of the
greatest literary figures in recent
history he is known for his uniquely
dark disorienting and surreal writing
style a style and quality still
particular to him that anything that
resembles it has come to be known and
referred to as Kafka esque to understand
his writing in the qualities of
Kafkaesque it is helpful to understand
his early life Kafka was born in Prague
in 1883 to a man named Hermann and a
woman named Julie his father was a
highly successful well-to-do businessman
who through sheer force of will and a
brash aggressive personality managed to
rise from the working-class build a
successful business marry a
well-educated woman and become a member
of higher middle society as parents tend
to do hermann hope for a child that
would measure up to his ideal stature of
a person Franz Kafka was not that Franz
was born a small anxious and sickly boy
and he mostly remained that way as a
result through no fault of his own
Franz would become a great source of
disappointment for his father and a sort
of psychological punching bag for him as
he attempted to mould Franz into who he
wished he was but could never be
throughout his adolescence friends
developed an urge to write as a means of
dealing with his increasing sense of
anxiety guilt and self-hatred of course
his father did not allow him to pursue
writing and ultimately define the
borders around Kafka's life forcing him
to pursue law as a profession
during his time studying law in college
Kafka continued writing and met one of
his only real friends max broad another
writer who would eventually convince
Kafka to publish his first three
collections of work these pieces sold
very poorly however and essentially went
unnoticed after college
Kafka would go on to work in a law
office and then for an insurance company
here Kafka would become subject to long
hours unpaid overtime massive amounts of
paperwork and absurd complex
bureaucratic systems Kafka was
understandably miserable while working
at the insurance company Kafka continued
writing on the side producing some of
his most notable pieces including the
trial the castle and America he did not
attempt to publish any of these at the
time however and even left much of his
work unfinished believing it to be
unworthy Kafka continued working at the
insurance company for the majority of
his remaining short life while
continuing to write around his work
scheduled in 1924 he died of
tuberculosis at age 41 Kafka never went
on to publish any more of his writing
nor did he ever personally receive any
success or recognition for the small
amount he did he died believing that his
work wasn't any good on his deathbed he
even instructed max Broad to burn all of
his unpublished manuscripts following
his death obviously fraud did not follow
Kafka's instructions because here we are
100 years later talking about him after
Kafka died Brod spent the following year
or so working to organize and publish
his notes and manuscripts over the
decade following Kafka would become one
of the most prominent literary and
philosophical figures of the 20th
century in other words one of the
greatest writers and thinkers of the
century lived his life with his work
buried in some drawer aware unaware or
indifferent to the fact that he was
sitting on some of the most significant
works in recent history he lived his
life in the eyes of his father an
inadequate disappointment and yet in the
eyes of history he's an immensely
important individual one can only wonder
how many individuals like Kafka have and
continued to walk this earth completely
disconnected or restricted from ever
seeing who they really are or could be
how many Kafka's have lived and died
without ever sharing their voice with
the world whose voice would have changed
it forever how many people never know
who they'll be after they're gone
fortunately for everyone other than
Kafka his work was saved and an entirely
new genre of thinking and writing
developed in his name Kafka esque
generally the term Kafka s tends to
refer to the bureaucratic nature of
capitalistic judiciary and government
systems the sort of complex unclear
processes in which no one individual
ever really has a comprehensive grasp on
what is going on and the system doesn't
really care but the quality of Kafka
esque also seems to extend much further
than this it is not necessarily
exemplified merely by what these systems
are but rather the reaction of the
individuals subjected to them and what
it might represent and one of his most
famous novels the trial the protagonist
Joseph K is suddenly arrested at his
home one morning the officers do not
inform k why is being arrested though
and he's then forced through a long
absurd trial in which nothing is ever
really explained or makes much sense the
trial is riddled with corruption and
disorderliness and by the end of the
novel after having me entered the entire
thing k is never told why he was
arrested and yet he remains guilty of
his final conviction in another one of
his more popular stories metamorphosis
the protagonist Gregor Samsa awakes into
having suddenly been turned into an
insect with no clear explanation the
first and recurring issues Gregor faces
throughout the novel are the problems of
getting to work dealing with his boss
and providing financially for his
inconsiderately needy family gregor of
course cannot do this he is a bug and so
he experiences increased dread trying to
deal with his situation while becoming a
useless nuisance to his family in both
stories the protagonists are faced with
sudden absurd circumstances there are no
explanations and in the end there is no
real chance of overcoming them they are
outmatched by the arbitrary senseless
obstacles they face in part because they
can't understand or control any of what
is happening the crux of Kafka style and
work seems to be carried by this
confrontation with the absurd a conflict
in which a character's efforts reasoning
and sense of the world are met with
inescapable parameters of senselessness
wherein success is both impossible and
in the end ultimately pointless and yet
they try anyway it's fair to argue that
one interpretation is that these
circumstances are emblematic of Kafka's
take on the human condition
specifically the unyielding desire for
answers and conquest over the
existential problems of anxiety guilt
absurdity and suffering paired with an
inability to ever really understand or
control the source of the problems and
effectively overcome them
but the kicker and perhaps most
important part is even in the face of
absurd despairing circumstances Kafka's
characters don't give up at least
initially they continue on and fight
against their situations trying to
reason understand or work their way out
of the senselessness but in the end it
is ultimately to no avail perhaps in
this Kafka is suggesting that the
struggle to find solace and
understanding is both inescapable and
impossible as conscious rational beings
we fight against the absurdity trying to
resolve the discrepancy between us and
the universe but ironically we only
serve to self perpetuate the very
struggle we are trying to resolve by
trying to resolve the unresolvable and
in this sense on some level we almost
want the struggle of course this is just
one interpretation ultimately because of
its vague surreal and inexplicable
quality Kafka's work lends itself to
nearly as many interpretations as
readers perhaps the idea is that we
should accept our absurd condition and
not take it so seriously
perhaps the ideas that we should and
must struggle against it or perhaps the
ideas that we can't know what the idea
is in truth only Kafka will ever have
known exactly what his work meant and
it's fair to speculate that in some
sense perhaps not even him what is
undeniable though is that Kafka's work
has left a lasting impact on literature
philosophy and humanity at large it has
helped readers around the world feel
less alone in their own hunches of truth
and moments of Kafka esque experiences
Kafka's own story is not necessarily
unusual his father although cruel his
life although sad neither were nor are
all that uncommon to be born into a
faulty family bad place in the world or
a weak body or brain to live and die
having never recognized one's full
potential to have been stuck in a
bureaucratic cog of a business
organization or government system to
have felt that guilt and anxiety of
existence for no clear reason we've all
at least at times experienced the Kafka
esque Kafka's work is not considered
great because it describes something
profoundly unique but because it
describes something mundane ly common in
a profound way an encapsulation of an
often indescribable experience a part of
life that touches us all when referring
to Kafka Reiter and rice once said that
his work helped her realize the
following approach in
don't bend don't water it down don't try
to make it logical
don't edit your own soul according to
the fashion rather follow your most
intense obsessions mercilessly Kafka's
works ought not to alleviate the soul
through remedies of false hope or
delusion but rather through the direct
confrontation with the darker aspects of
self by distorting reality to map more
accurately onto his own sense of human
experience he revealed a certain remedy
of unhindered self-examination and
carved out a place in the world for
others to do the same I think we ought
to read only the kind of books that
wound or stab us if the book we're
reading doesn't wake us up with a blow
to the head what are we reading for so
that it will make us happy good lord
we would be happy precisely if we had no
books wrote Kafka in a letter to a
friend although you might not have
shared this explicitly Kafka's working
bodies and reminds us not that we wish
to give up but that despite all the
absurdities and problems we wish to
continue we wish to struggle against the
universe and forge our own way we wish
to find and connect over honesty however
hard it may be
[Music]
you